we will not forgive
we will not forget
we will hunt you down
and make you pay
president biden vowing retribution for
isis terrorists responsible for killing
13 u.s service members in kabul after
his disastrous withdrawal led to one of
the most tragic outcomes imaginable the
deadliest day in 10 years for american
forces in afghanistan with four days to
go until august 31st
things aren't getting any better america
is still relying on the taliban for
protection the white house has been
warned that another attack in kabul is
likely
and the state department says they're in
contact with approximately 500 americans
in afghanistan who want to leave the
country
here's general jack keane ripping into
biden
this date certain that the president
announced going back in april has been
fundamentally flawed right from the
beginning and strategically has it has
cost us so much all of this has been
pushed too quickly and the results have
been horrible now we've got to date
certain
supposedly to take our people out but
we're going to walk out of here on the
31st and we know full well what we're
doing
we are leaving american citizens likely
by the hundreds
yesterday joe biden blamed donald trump
for the disaster in afghanistan but the
former president returned fire on
hannity last night it's a tough call and
it started out by saying that they will
be hit harder than any country has ever
been hit in the history of the world if
they do anything and in particular kill
our soldiers or even try to kill our
soldiers and even biden admitted today
that the reason they didn't kill any
soldiers and we haven't lost soldiers in
many many months because of the
agreement that we sent because i wanted
to get out i wish we never went in
because of what they're doing we're
leaving in disgrace we could have left
with great dignity we had them totally
under control every time we saw movement
would hit him with an f-18 and the
movement stopped
and just to underscore how dire the
situation is many people still trapped
in afghanistan have come to terms with
the idea that they won't get out alive
i know that i'm gonna get killed i think
i'm gonna laugh for a good thing
what i did i will never regret it
because i have tried to help people
let's go ladies first today kdp your
reaction to all you've seen in the last
24 hours
well in terms of people getting out the
white house is now shifting the globe
post again on that so a couple of weeks
ago they said anybody who wants to get
out will be able to get out which is
also a way for them to evade
responsibility for when people couldn't
get out and were getting stuck at
taliban checkpoints getting their
documentation ripped up whether it was
american citizens getting beaten by the
taliban or if it was siv
applicants and people were already
eligible to come here now we're hearing
that the united states will no longer
have a diplomatic process or uh function
on the ground when we leave on august
31st so the question now is well how are
you going to get americans out of the
country if you don't have a military
presence you don't have a diplomatic
presence and you're relying on the
taliban to kind of facilitate getting
these people out so that's the first
thing the idea that we are
even
contemplating leaving americans behind
is is is a new thing to i think the
american ethos and i think it's
absolutely despicable that that's even
on the table rather than saying we will
not leave until we get every single
person out
um so that's where they are on that in
terms of the attack that they keep
warning about
and the response that the president
promised not just yesterday but over the
course of the last week to retaliate
against any kind of attack on american
forces or troops well the time for that
is now the time is not to say well
another terrorist attack may happen
because it determines deterrence so they
could you know it's 1 30 a.m in kabul
hopefully there's planning going on and
people may be out right now conducting
those retaliatory attacks but this idea
that we're sitting back and saying we're
going to allow the child blend to
continue doing security and maybe we'll
see another terrorist attack rather than
acting immediately for deterrence
says quite a lot about where we are in
terms of our strength and the position
and that's because we don't have another
choice richard we've boxed ourselves in
and now have to rely on our enemy the
taliban
to run point for our airport
yeah i mean i think that's an
unfortunate situation that we are
relying on the taliban and not an afghan
government that we spent 20 years
propping up but how we got here was on
february 2020 we started negotiating
with the taliban and we excused the
afghan government from those
negotiations now don't get me wrong joe
biden
mangled this withdrawal but he was put
into a corner when he got in there and
he should have said at the beginning we
could have we should delete we we're i'm
not going to abide by any dates i'm
going to do everything in my power to
ensure and take as long as i need to to
get all the americans out but it's worth
pointing out that in this 2020 agreement
we allowed that we have released 5 000
taliban fighters that american troops
put in jail for doing bad things right
terrorists by any structure means of the
imagination report we've released them
from jail they're now fighting against
us and quote unquote guarding the
airports and guarding american troops
and i think it's also important to re
realize that the pentagon as well as the
state department as well as our
intelligence agencies have to be very
strategic about the next move that we
make when it comes to retaliating
against isis k why because we have
military troops on the ground and we
want to be sure that arm we don't lose
we've already lost 13 militarys i don't
want to lose another one because we made
a faulty decision so we've got to get
every everybody we can get out as fast
as we can and with that being said this
white house has gotten over a hundred
thousand people out in less than ten
days those people are not americans for
the majority of them by the way
yeah
but it's also worth a very small
delivery but it's also worth pointing
out that there has been warnings over
and over and over
no i'm not saying it's their fault oh
i'm saying there's the mornings giving
all over and over again to americans
saying you've got to get out because the
situation at some point in time we are
leaving oh so that's interesting though
so if if there were warnings for months
that they had to get out asap and the
embassy couldn't help him get out asap
then why was joe biden telling the
american people everything's fine i'm
not denying it
is going to be great and the taliban
wasn't going to quickly take over can't
have both things richard shame on this
government shame on this government
because the messaging has been uh you
guys we told you it was really dangerous
anyone who's in afghanistan they know
how dangerous it is all right they've
known that for some time you don't try
and get out a hundred thousand or five
hundred thousand people in two weeks
that is completely irresponsible it is
totally untenable and then you have the
secretary of state blaming people he's
blaming americans and then you have the
administration saying well you know what
every once while we leave something
behind we're talking about this before
the show like yeah you know when when i
moved from one house to another there
was a broken lamp so i didn't pack it in
the u-haul that you cannot do that with
american lives i don't trust this
government i don't think they're
listening to the people that they should
i think they are abandoning and
stranding uh people who are
brave and deserve to be saved and
they're not i don't think they have a
strategy they don't have any plans they
don't know what they're doing and this
you know if this is not the undoing of
this presidency i don't want to see how
bad it gets and hammer had the agreement
on set yesterday got felt it was
conditions based yeah biden could have
got out of it trump said he could have
moved it it was all about meeting those
conditions he wasn't locked in that that
was that's why the comparison doesn't
work because that was actually had
conditions that are now missing i'm not
calling for an impeachment
at all but i love how the media is
already scolding people for bringing up
impeachment in fact saying that how dare
you cheapened the process
this is from the same people who
screamed impeachment for four years who
impeached trump over a phone call you
tell me that this is less egregious than
a phone call
dead americans that's crazy but the
problem the problem why i'm not for
impeachment
there's no one to replace him kamala
give me a break uh there'd be a crisis
dinner every night crisis meals every
day but what does it what does this tell
you in the bigger picture
is that
this pitiful woke embrace by the
democrats have destroyed their party you
can't lead a country if you believe the
country is racist is guilty of the
original sin of racism you can't lead a
country if you if you abdicate the
responsibilities of the survival of a
government which is which is uh
immigration and law enforcement it's all
connected the abdication of
responsibility during the riots the
denigration of the police the conflation
of the immigration process with to
racism leads to a feeble foreign policy
a foreign policy in which only a feeble
response is the right one because you
don't you do not have the moral
authority to actually exercise the right
choices the democrats however i mean
this is where i'm going to defend joe
biden
you got to go to commercial break i'm
sorry
but i think you'll like my defense okay
he it's the democrat this is on the
democrats in the media not joe biden
joe biden was chosen by them to beat
trump and they knew his state they knew
he couldn't lead but they assumed win
first
worry about whether he can lead later so
now they're left holding the bag you
can't yell at joe you got him in there
right so they wanted joe to win
not governed and now he has to govern
and he can't
that's where we are that's why we're all
scared we're going like okay this was
all this political thing hiding but the
hunter biden laptop story the the entire
entire cabal of all these institutions
working to get him elected uh and then
lying about this consensus which is
again is ridiculous but anyway
that's my defense of joe biden i think
he'd be pleased with it well you can
tell the media is guilty you can see it
written all over their face